at this year's San Diego comic-con DC
Universe drew back the curtain on its
animated Harley Quinn series a hard-r
romp revolving around the off-the-rails
rule-breaker in the aftermath of her
breakup with the Joker via the reveal of
a fresh trailer Harley Quinn voiced by
the big bang series Kaley Cuoco
endeavors to carve her own path of chaos
and crime in the streets of Gotham
without the shadow of her former flame
looming overhead to do so she crosses
paths with some major DC Comics players
as well as a few new 52 pals such as
cyborg men an elderly cyborg voiced by
Seinfeld's Jason Alexander her ultimate
goal become a member of the supervillain
Alliance known as the Legion of Doom
with hammer swinging money falling
drinks clinking punches and kicks flying
plus plenty of expletives being tossed
around the Harley Quinn trailer proves
that anyone who Tunes in to the series
will see the up-and-coming criminal
queen pin of Gotham City in a brand new
way and while they're at it they'll get
to catch Harley taking down famed DC
Comics vigilantes like Aquaman and of
course Batman voiced by diedrich bader
returning to the role after 2000 dates
Brave and the bold animated series that
petulant primates poisonous ploy must be
prevented Harley Quinn features an
impressive cast of familiar voices
including Tony Hale as dr. psycho
Christopher Meloni as Commissioner James
Gordon and Wanda Sykes as the queen of
fables this isn't the first of Harley
Quinn that we've seen a fourth wall
breaking teaser dropped during New York
Comic Con in October of 2018 featuring a
DC fandom dissing poison ivy I think
they're gonna hate it whorls they hate
everything no waste comedy action
incredibly gratuitous violence by the
looks of this new trailer it seems
Harley Quinn will only get Wilder as the
first season rolls out lead voice
actress cuoco has teased that viewers
are in for an r-rated ride when the show
premieres hosting the Harley Quinn
trailer to her Instagram page koko wrote
this show is gonna blow your minds way
too much fun and a tad r-rated Harley
Quinn coming soon
also the Joker has an emoji but Harley
doesn't she is gonna be pissed the
raunchy Harley Quinn animated series
certainly feels like a shock to the DC
system but it
she only comes after a few other
legitimately r-rated animated projects
based on DC Comics characters the 2017
feature Justice League dark based on the
comic of the same name rocked the
r-rating so too did 28 teens Gotham by
Gaslight as well as 2016 s Batman The
Killing Joke the most recent r-rated
animated flick to come from Warner
Brothers actually includes the cupid of
crime herself 2018 Suicide Squad hell to
pay
C's Amanda Waller assembling a brand new
task force ex roster with Harley Quinn
and company hunting down the coveted to
get out of hell free card so well DC
universes upcoming Harley Quinn show is
certainly going to drop some jaws and
widen some eyes it follows a handful of
other adult aimed animated flicks that
exist in the same comic book realm
perhaps reception to the new series will
be so strong that it motivates Warner
Brothers animation to greenlight
additional series in the same vein as
Harley Quinn in' maybe even some focused
on groups like The Suicide Squad or the
birds of prey both of which have had
Harley on board only time will tell if
the r-rated Harley Quinn becomes DC's
animated answer to Marvel's Deadpool or
just a failed experiment and
envelope-pushing check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite DC
characters are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]